I got to tell you you know when I went
back and watch that Saturn in live
sketch that you're in and you're on with
Adam Sandler and you were mill at a
restaurant yes you are the guy who puts
pepper on his salad and you're training
young Adam Sandler who seems to be
mentally deranged in his prime Steve
corn wrote it and it's still the rhythm
of it like they were so into the pepper
and giving the pepper that it got into
ice on the air show it got kind of into
that sexual rhythm of like you know like
a pepper yeah you did and I'm I'm behind
Tim Meadows I'm going your leg up there
but yeah I mean it's just so the
audience is going [ __ ] and then
Chris Farley just plays a guy in the
sketch and he has one line while Thank
You pepper boy right so all week long is
going to Bob Thank You pepper boy in the
practice show why Thank You pepper boy
the air show Sandler goes okay you bring
and pepper so Sandler's go in his little
voice and it goes - Farley with the
pepper thing goes a fresh pepper and all
of a sudden Farley just becomes gigantic
bullfrog it goes turns purple but I
thought let's not break cuz this sketch
is so good ruined that sketch was so
perfect if Sandler had started laughing
yes it would and Farley was infamous for
that he could make people laugh yeah he
just had his Chin's down and he just so
sailor turns to me away from cameras I'm
just shaking and purple and I stay in
character and I just said to him adult
up break oh did you say yeah I said as
well don't a break yeah which means
don't you laugh it around us don't laugh
because mr. classics this sketch is too
good